listen you have to know something yeah
everybody here any human being in this
area on all the world
not against a beat everybody like life
even Hamas in Gaza they like life they
like peace but peace not like what you
want Moto sir if I want to buy something
from you if I create for your price and
I am happy for your things I will buy it
so our situation here what's going with
the Israeli we are not against of Israel
as people Jewish we are against of
occupation if you remember what's
happened with Russia and okra India
look
look one year Russia they have a problem
and they're afraid from NATO come to
close to the going inside okrania all
the world
and all the arming of the world against
Russia how come I am Refugee in my land
why I'm lost my house did I make
something for Israel did I did my Hitler
was my cousin did I make anything for
the Jews in the world me and my family
and the Palestinians do you have hope
for peace
my age is 50 years I have seven kids no
hope if I told I have hope I'm job and
if you want to say the truth there is no
justice in the world
if you are strong
everybody Afraid from you if you are not
everybody
kill you they make you like this by your
foot
that's what happened
there is no peace my friend if you want
to see the peace come to our camp where
I live you will cry
you will cry you see our peace what are
the conditions like
in uh in the camp my friend they're
waiting for water water you know what's
been water yeah in Europe the dog he
lived in good condition dog animals how
come a human being not have water water
to drink I asked you about anger What
about love you got love in your heart
well I love everybody even the Jews they
kill us they destroy our houses I'm not
looked to fight I'm not looking to kill
I am against the violence we love your
kids to live in good condition the
Israeli side and the Palestinian we are
against the violent we don't want to see
more blood
we want to destroy this wall you come to
me I come to you that's it
That's My Hope thank you my brothers not
so nice it's pretty good
Hello friends
I recently traveled to the West Bank and
spoke with many Palestinian people there
from all walks of life there was anger
and there was hope in their voice in
their eyes in their stories in ways that
I probably can't express those words but
I wanted to begin to experience directly
most conversations were offline but a
few were on camera and I include those
latter ones here in this video
I'm not a journalist nor a documentary
filmmaker just a fellow human being
trying to understand the struggles and
the beauty of other people
and I just sometimes might bring a
camera along
so I ask for your forgiveness if I fall
short of what I could have done with
this opportunity I work hard to improve
and I will do many more videos like
these
I love you all
so I think a lot of people would be
surprised to see a Palestinian who's a
Christian yes is there a tension in that
can you explain what it's like to be you
Yes actually because I've been to
America once when I was there and I said
that I'm Palestinian Christians and they
how come you are Palestinian Christians
they don't know that in Palestine they
are Christian people Palestinian
Christians are exist since Jesus was
born in the house that I lived in it
it's 200 years old and it was my grand
grandfather who lived in this and my
grandfather and my father and me in the
same house in this area in Palestine
especially you can see Christians and
Muslims together living by side by side
and as a neighbors as we go to the
universities together we work together
we do everything together what aspects
of life has made difficult here because
of the tension between Israel and
Palestine yes
since Jesus was born it was occupied by
many till now
occupation after occupations the best
Palestine through the Turkish the
British Egyptian Jordanian and that was
the last is the Israeli so there's quite
a bit of tension between the various
religions here yes what gives you hope
in the future that's right yes because
you know
Christianity Muslims and Judaism and
which is means
that all praise the Lord this makes me
feel very happy because I'm not a judge
to judge rather religious I'm I'm just
praying and God will judge everyone as
what he believes but the most important
thing between the three major religions
it's just to have most important to have
love
first of all how long have you lived
here my father or second generation
Refugee I'm a third generation and my
grandfather first to live in 1948. what
does it mean to be a refugee Refugee
that uh that's a long story you know
Palestinians that became a refugee in
1908 when you know they lost their
Homeland they became refugees a lot of
them they live in Jordan Syria Lebanon
and everywhere in Palestine you know
Palestines get divided to West Bank Gaza
East Jerusalem Jordan Valley do you have
hope for peace in the region of course I
do have hope because nothing lasts
forever you know you know what that
means nothing lasts forever we are not
alone we have a lot of solidarity from
the Jewish Community from the Christian
Community from the whole world but
something does something to do with
governments and politicians they are you
know trying to control over one state
equal rights equalism because Jewish
Christians and Muslims they have always
lived to begin together during the
British mandate during the ultimate time
for decades the only hope for people to
live peacefully together it's related to
one word which is occupation if
occupation ends there's no reason for
bossing us to fight it's no reason for
through Rockets black people I think
they have a legitimate try to resist the
last CM people in general they're nice
people not what the media says about us
you know it's crazy when you resist they
call you a terrorist it's a crazy world
that we live in it we are in the 21st
century and we still occupied so one day
that's why again I said like I started
saying nothing lasts forever exactly
eventually this occupation will end and
I do believe that history is repeating
solved but seems to me people they
didn't learn from the history you know
right
people who get the power they want to
just keep
going up you know but at least we are
not alone in this damn world
how long have you lived here I lived in
Mississippi I bought in this city since
I born until now I grew up in this town
there are a lot of people that have
anger towards Israel hate towards Israel
I will give you example
like if someone come to fight your
family and to enjoy your home you will
stand closing your hand if someone
killed your brother killed your father
you will be easy you will be as as super
crazy
this is what's happened with Palestinian
a lot of Palestine was killed for no
reason what gives you hope about the
future
the situation is getting worse and worse
and worse today they close all over
around Batman because there's something
happen there's a fight between Boston as
well and if you go all over around the
city all the entrance of the city it's a
close second thing I want to lose
something I don't like politics so much
because you know in the end we are all a
human doesn't matter if you are
Palestinian or Israeli or Russian or
American doesn't matter what your
religious Christian Muslim you and then
well we are all human what we want we
want just peace we want to live in peace
we don't want any more fight we want to
have our freedom to travel to go
wherever we want
and that's it
it looks good what's uh tell us about
the coffee I make very good coffee and
very good tea I make the tea with men
cinnamon Sage fine Ginger coriander
Rosemary lemon juice
this one is
working
[Laughter]
[Music]